bonjour bienvenue dans ces caches une
émission qui va vous entraîner jusque
dans l' empire du milieu qui n'a rien à
voir avec le centre
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ces
caches une émission consacrée cette
semaine à l' empire du milieu et si la
prochaine crise financière venait de
chine a pour en parler chez olivier
delamarche bien sûr bonjour olivier
bonjour aux seuls à vos côtés et notre
contributrice à du mois véronique riches
florès économiste indépendante et
présidente de riches florès reasearch
bonjour léonie crise perdure à celle
dont je rêvais toujours pas remis
douze ans après la crise des subprimes
aux états unis ce raid se dirige-t-on
vers une nouvelle crise financière à la
lehman brothers evergrande c'est le nom
du géant chinois de la construction un
géant qui pourtant croule sous une
gigantesque dette explications avec le
tiroir cash d'antoine d'assas
[Musique]
depuis quelques semaines les marchés
sont quelque peu affolée en alerte face
à une menace chinoise qui pourrait bien
causer un nouveau krach boursier de
grande ampleur on parle quand même d'un
scénario à la lehman brothers en 2008
evergrande comme son nom ne l'indiqué
pas est une entreprise immobilière
chinoise qui a cumulé quelques 300
milliards de dollars de dettes
c'est carrément l'entreprise immobilière
la plus endettée du monde elle a eu
recours à de nombreux emprunts pour
acheter depuis la fin des années 90
toujours plus de terrain et miser sur
une demande et une hausse des prix
soutenus en 2015 en pleine crise
financière l'entreprise continue à
emprunter pour éviter de s'écrouler et
accumule encore et encore de la dette
dernièrement le coc vider la fermeture
forcée de centres commerciaux qu'elle
gère pouvait assène un coup de plus fin
2020 les autorités chinoises se fâche
tout rouge et décide de limiter les
emprunts des entreprises endettées et
freiner la spéculation immobilière dans
le pays
pris à la gorge le géant immobilier doit
maintenant rembourser sans pouvoir
continuer à emprunter ce qui vu le
montant de sa dette est loin d'être
évident sa faillite pourrait ainsi se
répercuter sur tous ceux qui détiennent
de la dette de l'entreprise en chine
bien sûr mais il y a également blackrock
amundi ou hsbc
evergrande n'est pas la seule entreprise
immobilière chinoise dans la galère
c'était le cas également de fantasia a
rien à voir avec le dessin animé une
autre firme dans l'immobilier qui vient
d'annoncer qu'elle n'était pas en mesure
de rembourser sa dette et voilà pour
ceux qui ne connaissaient pas evergrande
olivier peut-on comparer la chèvre à
lehman brothers est ce les mêmes profils
non pas du tout pourquoi parce que le le
marché chinois est très très ferme et
finalement si vous voulez donc vous avez
vous n'avez pas le phénomène de
contagion que vous pouvez avoir que vous
avez pu avoir avec lehman brothers alors
ça ne veut pas dire que certaines firmes
et certaines banques ne détiennent pas
du tout de d'obligations
dévergonde vous avez hsbc qui est la
première à en avoir un joli paquet mais
vous avez aussi d'autres d'autres
banques qui sont cités dans la masse des
obligataires de développement maintenant
tout va dépendre de la façon dont l'état
chinois va gérer la chose
est ce que il sauve les les détenteurs
d'obligations en interne et qui plante
les détenteurs d'obligations
externe ou est ce que
il règle la note pour pour evergrande on
n'en sait rien pour l'instant on ne sait
pas comment ça va se passer les chinois
vont probablement en profiter pour
reprendre de toute façon la main sur la
société comme ils l'ont fait sur
d'autres secteurs l'a récemment et
donc on va il faut attendre pour savoir
à quelle sauce les chinois vont nous
manger mais
je ne je ne pense pas que ça déclenche
quoi que ce soit comme comme panique à
la lehman brothers 1 / sur cette
faillite dévergonde c'est quelque chose
en plus qu'on connaît depuis très
longtemps c'est à dire la bulle
immobilière le le fait que vous avez une
dette qui sera de toute façon
irremboursable
de sur les l'immobilier chinois c'est
quelque chose pas une découverte si vous
voulez et donc il fallait on leur on le
savait depuis longtemps donc ya pas deux
il n'ya rien nouveau sous le soleil là
on fait semblant de s'en apercevoir
maintenant mais c'est quelque chose qui
court depuis rabat un moment seulement
justement lésé puisque vous parlez à de
dettes evergrande c'est donc 260
milliards d'euros de dette soit 2% du
pib chinois le groupe emploie 200 mille
personnes et génère plus de 2 millions à
d'emplois indirects 8500 entreprises
travaillent avec ce promoteur depuis la
mi septembre le groupe est donc
confronté à des difficultés de paiement
véronique riches florès comment
evergrande le deuxième groupe immobilier
du pays at il pu se retrouver dans cette
situation
ah mais en fait c'est pas compliqué et
je dirais qu'il n'est pas le seul à se
retrouver dans cette situation il ya des
petits et des moyens des plus grands
evergrande un petit peu partout en chine
n'est pas qu'en chine d'ailleurs il ya
plusieurs éléments il faut remonter
peut-être au lendemain de la crise
financière de 2008 quand la chine a
voulu
soutenir de rattrapage domestique de son
économie ce rattrapage s'est fait
énormément à coup de crédits et d'un
endettement pharamineux et puis après
vous avez eu une deuxième étape pour
riches de
7.5 ont été les cas était le premier
tiers de de la décennie prouesses
économiques finalement la chine s'est
retrouvé face à des investissements
étrangers massifs notamment dans
l'immobilier alors pourquoi l'immobilier
parce que forcément il ya une population
très importante il ya beaucoup de flux
migratoires des campagnes vers les
villes des besoins de reconstruction et
d'extension des huiles qui sont
faramineux d'où quelque chose ce marché
très très prospère qui est qui a
incontestablement
profitez également de d'une sorte de
spéculation et là encore on revient au
sujet des politiques de banques
centrales des injections de liquidités
parle d'à travers le monde qui ont
favorisé la spéculation alors à partir
de là on avait des taux d'intérêt en
chine comme ailleurs un peu moins bas
mais tout de même très bas et que font
que dans ces cas là les investisseurs
qui cherchent du rendement ils prêtent
allègrement à des entreprises qui ont
pas toujours les reins solides qui sont
pas toujours sur des secteurs
durablement porteur mais là pour le coup
pendant pas mal d'années est un secteur
porteur donc on a prêté à une société
qui avait besoin d'argent pour étendre
son pouvoir et son business et jusqu'à
quand jusqu'à la crise sanitaire où tout
d'un coup a déjà il y avait plusieurs
signes inde un marché en surchauffe sur
l'immobilier dans plusieurs villes
chinoises
chinoise pardon et puis interruption du
marché avec un effondrement du marché
pendant sa période de kovy d'alors nous
d'europe on a l'impression que ça s'est
arrêté en chine au bout de trois
semaines qui a pas eu de problème de
sanitaires je pense que sur le plan
domestique les choses ont été un peu
plus saignante et un peu plus sévères et
qu'en l'occurrence cette entreprise
hyper endetté tout d'un coup c'est
retrouver sans ressource sans revenu
donc effectivement faillite si vous avez
simultanément un durcissement de la
législation qui empêche de ceux de
continuer à se présenter sur le marché
pour faire face à vos impératifs de
remboursement et bien voilà c'est une
histoire evergrande et elle est
absolument pas unique elle et elle était
attendue ça fait plusieurs années et
beaucoup d'économistes d'ailleurs qui
peut être un peu tôt on imaginer que le
système de surendettement allait éclater
ce qu'ils aient pu alors par rapport à
ce que disait olivier
oui ça ne ressemble absolument pas à
lehman brothers à ceci près que cette
explosion de la dette et la dette des
entreprises chinoises n'est pas une
spécificité chinoise le marché de la
dette des entreprises a été l'un des
marchés les plus les plus attractifs et
les plus prospères ces dernières années
c'est pas pour rien qu au début de la
crise sanitaire l'an dernier la réserve
fédérale américaine dans les
dispositions qu'elle a prises
immédiatement
à
à acheter dès de tf2 crédit corporate
parce qu'effectivement ce crédit aux
entreprises donc et 1 1 est devenu un
pôle financier
considérable et c'est là j'ai
l'impression mois qu'on a un peu plus de
similitudes avec la situation qui était
celle dans laquelle lehman brothers à
l'essai a été laissée faire faillite
parce qu'effectivement
on a un marché en parfaite ébullition
dans le monde entier souvent avec des
investisseurs qui ont souvent
sous-estimé le risque parce qu'on
cherche le rendement et que dans ces
conditions là il suffit quelquefois d'un
maillon a pu maillot est gros plus c'est
risqué d'un maillon qui sautent dans
cette chaîne pour faire pour avoir des
effets de propagation globaux de l'effet
boule de neige et c'est là à mon avis
qu'on peut s'interroger sur les
conséquences plus global d'une faillite
de dévergonder et d'autres entreprises
immobilières chinoises
olivier je suis pas tout à fait d'accord
parce que
quand on était quand on a eu le le krach
du à al iman brothers
on était encore dans un marché là nous
ne sommes plus dans un marché nous
sommes dans un régime de prix
administrés par les banques centrales
donc si vous voulez 200 milliards c'est
rien pour une banque centrale donc si
elle veut régler le problème evergrande
demain et puis les autres d'ailleurs
suffi qu'elle fasse tourner la planche à
billets et aujourd'hui on est en train
de tout régler comme ça c'est à dire en
faisant tourner la planche à billets en
plus ils n'ont pas de chance les chinois
ils n'ont pas certains de nos économies
ce qui nous explique depuis des années
que la dette c'est pas un problème alors
quelques fois ça se rappelle un peu à
eux et puis tout d'un coup on s'aperçoit
que ça peut poser des problèmes quand
même à certaines sociétés mais nous en
avons quelques uns de célèbres qui
passent leur temps à nous expliquer que
toute façon la dette c'est à rien il
suffit de là il suffit de faire un high
tof et puis que ça se passe bien et que
et que c'est pas un problème alors
malheureusement le gouvernement chinois
n'avait pas le heures d'avoir ces
économistes qu'on voit sur les plateau
de bfm assez régulièrement pour leur
expliquer que finalement c'était pas
grave hein donc et donc ils sont
aujourd'hui un petit peu embêté non mais
je pense que je sais ce que j'ai dit au
début je pense que tout va dépendre de
la façon dont la chine va régler le
problème est-ce qu'ils vont laisser
l'art vase à l'extérieur et puis et puis
régler leurs problèmes en interne pour
qu'il n'y ait pas de de panique parce
qu'il ya déjà quand même des débuts de
panique de 2,2 de gens qui ont qui ont
de la dette chez ocz evergrande et est
donc
ça peut ça pourrait se faire comme ça ça
laissera des ardoises en certaines
banques les banques centrales des pays
de ces banques s'arrangeront pourrait
mettre un peu de monnaie pour les
soutenir et puis voilà c'est à dire que
comme on vous dit depuis des lustres que
il n'y a aucune conséquence à la planche
à billets puisque il suffit simplement
de continuer et qu' il n'y a jamais de
conséquence à rien d'ailleurs ni à la
dette ni à la planche à billets et bien
continuons joyeusement
justement olivier on parlera des marges
de manoeuvre des autorités chinoises ce
sera juste après la cub
bienvenue dans ces cas chez vous nous
rejoignez au sommaire cette semaine la
sphère evergrande et aux côtés d'olivier
notre contributrice du mois véronique
riches florès économiste indépendante et
présidente de riches florès reasearch on
l'a dire les autorités à chinoises
surveillent evergrande comme le lait sur
le feu pour autant ont-elles des marges
de manoeuvre je pense que les autorités
ont les moyens de gérer la situation a
déclaré le directeur du département
chargé des marchés de capitaux au fmi
pour le moment les autorités chinoises
restent muettes une inaction qui
inquiète tout de même le fond la
formation potentiel de cercle vicieux
macro financiers dans un contexte de
ralentissement de la croissance du
crédit souligne l'urgence des
restructurations et de réforme complète
extraits du rapport du fonds sur la
stabilité financière alors véronique
riches florès quelles sont concrètement
les options qui s'offrent aux autorités
chinois et comment peut-on expliquer
cette inaction
je pense que les options ou les réponses
sont politiques et que c'est un choix
politique qui
dominera finalement la décision de la
chine et les actions qui sont
entreprises comme l'a dit olivier c'est
pas un problème on peut arracher la
dette on peut sécuriser
les les intérêts les remboursements
d'intérêts par de la planche à billets
ça c'est pas ça peut se faire et
probablement qu'une bonne partie sera
réglée comme ça après il faut on voit
bien qu'on a à faire un gouvernement
chinois qui depuis quelques trimestres
quand même un petit excès
d'autoritarisme et cherche j'ai
l'impression je suis pas sûr d'avoir
toute la visibilité 'un sur ce qui ce
qui est à l'origine de ces agissements
mais un gouvernement chinois qui veut
reprendre la main reprendre la main sur
un système financier qui le dépasse sur
des nouvelles technologiques et le
dépasse qui sont qui éloigne qui
s'éloigne de plus en plus de la du
pouvoir politique et et que dans ce
contexte là y compris dans cette lutte
affiché pour en faveur d'une société
plus égale au moins inégalitaire on
comprendrait que le gouvernement chinois
soit tenté de se servir au moins de
cette affaire comme d'un
comme d'un
agitateur d'un spectre pour calmer un
petit peu la spéculation dans le pays et
c'est peut-être ce qui justifie que le
gouvernement n'agit ce pas précisément
pour créer un petit peu de stress et je
dirais que d'un point de vue global
d'ailleurs quand on voit à quel point
les dettes des entreprises secteur
immobilier de beaucoup d'autres secteurs
1 ont explosé ces derniers temps
finalement que le gouvernement chinois
viennent un petit peu agité le spectre
d'une crise systémique ou financières
c'est plutôt bienvenu en réalité parce
que ça peut permettre effectivement de
calmer un petit peu la spéculation qui
est quand même très forte à tous les
niveaux
après il ya une question d'équilibré
vous l'avez dit les le chinois moyen est
très exposée à l'immobilier
il la rate au départ un très élevé on le
sait et systèmes de retraite sont très
très mal loti et donc le bien
l'acquisition immobilière a représenté à
une valeur un peu sacré au delà des
aspects spéculatifs qui sont nombreux
aussi c'est quand même le bien
patrimonial sur le compte sur lequel
compte beaucoup de chinois pour
l'immédiat et le futur et donc il faut
le gouvernement joue sur un peu sur des
oeufs d'ailleurs si il n'est pas capable
de sauver aider des verts grands des
éclats la lame de fond emporte dans son
sillage une grande partie des épargnants
et du marché immobilier alors ça se
retournera sans doute contre lui voilà
donc c'est ce jeu politique est
extrêmement compliqué parce que sinon
effectivement on rachèterait les
obligations ont bouclé on enfoncerait le
dossier puis voilà on passera à autre
chose non je pense qu'à une volonté de
reprendre en main la main un peu la main
et en même temps de protéger en équipe
sociale qui est un petit peu fragilisé
il faut bien le dire et puis il ya la
partie extérieure au sénat c'est à dire
que il ya une depuis là plusieurs
plusieurs semestre vous avez quand même
une une guerre entre les états unis la
chine qui est une guerre plus un
monétaire d'ailleurs qu'une guerre qu
une guerre commerciale et et là ils ont
l'occasion rêvée un de faire un peu de
chantage ils ont l'occasion rêvée
d'agiter aussi vers l'extérieur
en disant vous avez vos banques qui sont
qui sont impliqués dans la dette des
verts gironde
on les sauve on les sauve pas enfin je
veux dire donc il ya il ya un petit jeu
vers l'intérieur il ya un jeu aussi vers
l'extérieur et je pense que on va on va
probablement avoir des nouvelles bientôt
le
lay sont en phase ii de reprise en main
de mai mais de beaucoup de secteurs sur
sur le semestre rappelez vous la petite
mésaventure de monsieur jack ma qui
avait disparu pendant quelques semaines
et à qui on a dû expliquer la vie et
et donner de nouvelles bases de
réflexion un monsieur jacques mahé puis
il a réapparu et tout d'un coup ils
étaient plus - moins arrogant et plus
gentil donc
ils l'ont fait sur les entreprises
formation en ligne ils l'ont fait sur
beaucoup de secteurs donc le secteur
immobilier je pense qu'il profite de
cette de cette faillite de d'evergrande
ces difficultés dévergonde pour aussi
reprendre le secteur immobilier en main
et puis en effet la spéculation et la
dette qui a eu là dessus mais faux faux
faux quand même imaginer que depuis
depuis plusieurs années le la part
de l'investissement de la part du pib
consacrée à l'investissement en chine
est ahurissante c'est bien plus que tous
les autres pays donc on sait qu'à un
moment et quand on voit l'explosion de
la bête sur les sur les dernières années
sur les dix dernières années quand on
voit l'explosion de la dette on savait
que toute façon il y avait quelque chose
qui ne collerait pas un moment que les
banques étaient en train avec en plus
avec le ch toute la partie shadow
banking
on savait qu'ils avaient des dettes
pourries qui allait à un moment
ressortir deux sous le tapis elles sont
en train de ressortir d'autres sous le
tapis véronique riches florès un boa
pour terminer sur cette déclaration de
christine lagarde pour le moment nous
assistons à un impact et à une
exposition centrée sur la chine je ne
peux pas parler pour les états unis je
peux dire pour l'europe que son
exposition directe est limité si vous
êtes d'accord pas d'inquiétude pour le
moment en ce qui concerne le lieu des
répercussions c'est un peu ce que je
disais tout à l'heure c'est à dire la
répercussion directe elle est faible là
où on a affalé faible parce
qu'effectivement à part quelques bancs
que quelques fonds qui ont effectivement
des obligations evergrande et d'autres
d'ailleurs d'autres boîtes de
l'immobilier chinois
mais je crois que c'est pas tellement ça
le problème est là encore on noie le
poisson la vérité c'est que on a un
marché de la dette des entreprises qui a
pris des proportions gigantesques en
chine et dans beaucoup de pays et qui
effectivement alors le fuit direct je
suis assez d'accord avec ce que dit
madame lagarde les fûts indirects j'en
suis beaucoup moins mois sur à un moment
donné où les banques centrales ne
l'oublions pas parce que l'inflation ben
à force d'avoir injecté des liquidités
dans l'économie d'inflation est là en
tout cas celle des matières premières et
que les banques centrales sont en train
de nous dire ah bah tiens on va on va
quand même commencer à réduire la
voilure donc on voit bien que la le
l'equilibre si on peut dire atteint
peut-être ou frôlé ses limites voilà je
veux dire atteint mais en tout cas va
aller chatouiller et ça ça peut
effectivement avoir des répercussions
directes sur le l'immobilier sur le
crédit
les placements en europe effectivement
merci beaucoup et véronique riches
florès d'avoir été parmi nous dans cette
émission je rappelle que vous êtes
économiste et présidente de riches
florès reasearch on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine olivier la place aux
questions et aux commentaires cash
et on démarre avec ce commentaire il est
signé al au quoi si la vente des
sous-marins est annulé le transfert de
technologie il est également c'est donc
une partie du savoir-faire français qui
restent en france c'est plutôt une bonne
nouvelle à l'heure où tout le monde
défend sa souveraineté sur tout
médicament puce électronique terreur etc
alors pourquoi tout ce cinéma
c'est vrai réjouissons nous de cette
fait piquer le contrat par les
américains
alors on sera souverain mais pauvre
ces lieux que pas souvent et riche
commentaires à présent à 2 philippe
lepeltier je ne suis pas tout à fait
d'accord avec ce qui est dit je pense
que l'inflation est difficile à
maîtriser le grand risque c'est l'hyper
inflation celle là on ne la maîtrisent
pas du tout c'est comme une panique
collective et c'est ce qui nous attend
qu'est-ce que vous n'avez pas compris
dans ce que j'ai dit quand j'ai dit que
l'inflation s'était comme le dentifrice
c'était très facile de la faire sortir
c'était impossible à faire rentrer dans
le tube
merci olivier c'est la fin de cette
émission merci de votre fidélité pour
voir ou revoir nos précédentes
l'émission rendez vous sur notre site
internet à l'adresse rt france point tv
et n'oubliez pas de réagir aux émissions
sur les réseaux sociaux avec le hashtag
rtcs h on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine en attendant olivier je crois
que vous aviez une petite annonce à
faire oui le 27 octobre à 18h sur
télégramme nous allons nous retrouver
dans le salon vocal de rt france pour
parler économie pour parler politique
l'état de la france aussi sera abordée
et donc vous pourrez me poser toutes vos
questions en direct
et rendez vous est pris merci olivier et
puis votre derniers mois à la dette
s'est jamais un problème jusqu'au jour
où ça le devient